Вітаю, я Ольга Дудар.
Історик, вчитель, викладач.
Я дуже дякую, що мене
позвали на цей предмет.
Викладач сподобався - я на сто відсотків
впевнений, що це дасть результат.
Я запрошую вас поговорити про
дуже складну тему, доволі драматичну,
про життя українських земель в
складі Польщі у міжвоєнний період.
Чому драматичну?
Через те, що процеси,
які почались і тривали між
Першою і Другою Світовою війною,
насправді впливають на українсько-польські
відносини і до сьогоднішнього дня.
Що трапилось? Як все відбувалось?
Запрошую вас глибше
дізнатися про цю тему.
Але, перш ніж ми з вами почнемо
працювати, давайте пригадаємо.
Найперше, в складі якої
держави була Західна Україна,
західно-українські землі
до Першої світової війни?
Можливо ви пам’ятаєте.
От Наддніпрянська Україна
була у складі Російської Імперії,
а західноукраїнські землі
були у складі якої імперії?
Австро-Угорська!
Молодці, пригадали!
Отже, яким же чином,
після Австро-Угорщини,
польські можновладці
захопили землі України?
Це відбулося в 1919 році.
Чому Східна Галичина, яка до
цього проголосила незалежність
Західно-Українська Народна Республіка, яка
боролася за створення суверенної держави
яка об’єдналася, до речі, можливо ви
пам’ятаєте коли був акт злуки УНР і ЗУНР?
От якраз в цьому році, в якому
рада після Антанти вирішила,
що Східна Галичина все таки
буде належати до Польщі. Чому?
Польській уряд наголошував
- на сході наростає
загроза від новоутвореної
більшовицької Росії
і Польща брала на себе забов'язання
бути таким своєрідним буфером,
але Антанта розуміла,
що ситуація може мінятися.
Тому Східній Галичині надали
такого статусу (тимчасового),
що Польща буде його
контролювати до того, як ліга націй,
така міжнародна організація,
яка мала опікуватись
всіма цими складними
питаннями міжнародної політики,
пізніше вирішить статус -
що буде з Галичиною надалі.
На яких умовах Антанта
визнавала належність
Східної Галичини до Польської Республіки?
Як ви думаєте, що могли
вимагати європейці від поляків
в обмін на те, що вони
погоджуються визнати
право Польщі поки що
керувати цими землями?
Що могли поляки обіцяти такого?
Це дуже просте рішення,
але вони його не виконували.
Як ви думаєте?
Уявіть собі, представники
Польщі перед послами
Антанти говорять, що
віддайте нам Східну Галичину.
Я, звичайно, дуже все це спрощую.
Що вони могли пообіцяти
такого, що Антанта сказала:
"Ну так. В таких умовах
складних повоєнних,
там економічна криза,
більшовики наступають»?
Не знаю, можливо - стримувати агресію.
Так, вирішили що можна пообіцяти Антанті
дотримання прав українських
земель і потім проводили свою політику.
Зверніть, будь ласка, увагу на карту.
Ось тут кольором виділені ті території
України, які належали до Польщі.
Разом із землями Білорусії,
які теж приєднались до Польщі.
Це була дуже велика
частинка Польської держави.
Наприклад, якщо в той момент
територія УРСР - це вся територія України,
яка не зафарбована кольором -
вона складала близько 450000 км.кв.
То територія, яка належала
до Польщі це 130000 км.кв.
Це доволі значні території.
Плюс там проживало понад 10 мільйонів
осіб - і це 30% від населення Польщі.
Але, українські землі вони не
були такими однорідно-українськими.
Якщо ми говоримо про сільські регіони,
то там українці складали більшість.
Якщо ми говоримо про
міста, хто там проживав?
Можливо ви пам'ятаєте,
представники яких націй?
Оскільки ці землі входили раніше
до складу Австро-Угорщини,
а перед цим до складу Речі
Посполитої, то - звичайно що...
Венгри?
Ні. Ну, якщо увійшли в склад
Польщі? Чому поляки боролися?
Звичайно. І у Львові
до сих пір багато місць,
пов'язаних саме з історією
Польщі. Крім того - це євреї.
У Львові українці не були більшістю.
В містах ситуація - ось
цей національний склад
набагато відрізнявся від
того, як жилось селянам.
І це теж доволі характерно
для Західної України через те,
що міста швидше призвичаїлись
до польської політики,
а селяни чинили опір через те,
що Польща захищала свої інтереси.
Яким був правовий статус?
Спочатку дотримувались того, що обіцяли.
Східна Галичина
поділялась на три воєводства,
оскільки була включена і
територія Західної Волині.
І це певна різниця.
Давайте пригадаємо, в Україні більшість
народу зараз дотримується якої релігії?
Православної! Правильно!
Отже, і так само було
на Волинських землях,
які потрапили під контроль Польщі,
там проживали православні.
На Східній Галичині більшість
складають греко-католики.
Католики - це будуть поляки,
а українці греко-католики.
І, відповідно, ще така релігійна різниця,
поляки теж її використовували,
оскільки хотіли змінити
віросповідання у волинських
землях, запровадити
якісь нові, скажімо так,
процедури церковні, ритуали.
Греко-католицька церква це не підтримувала
крім того - для того, щоб розбавити.
Давайте поміркуємо, якщо одна
держава захопила землі іншої держави?
Яку політику вона буде
проводить, щоб місцеве населення
менше чинило опір, не влаштовувало
повстання, корилося владі?
Що треба зробити, щоб
зменшити їхній вплив?
Стати більш тоталітарними.
Так, впливати тоталітарно, тобто
змушувати виконувати розпорядження влади.
А якщо більш прагматичний
шлях? Кого можна туди?
Ну, своїх.
Правильно! Заселяти туди поляків,
тобто розбавляти місцеве населення
поляками, які звичайно будуть
лояльнішими до польського уряду.
І ми можемо говорити про те,
що умовно польська політика, вона
проходила в три етапи.
На першому етапі, коли
намагались вирішити як все владнати,
як організувати, які
запровадити державні установи.
На другому етапі шукали
компроміс і далі через те,
що світова економічна криза переддень
війни, тиск на українців посилюється.
Ми можемо говорити про
полонізацію Східної Галичини.
Так? Тобто, що все, починаючи від
державного управління,
закінчуючи освітою, культурою - все це
буде перебудовуватись на польський лад.
Перше, звичайно, що
запровадження отих органів
управління і тих законів,
які існували в Польщі.
Це зрозуміло.
В принципі, так чинять всі держави.
Далі ліквідувати, знищити всі організації,
які до цього захищали інтереси українців.
Можливо ви знаєте, що таке Пласт?
Я знала, але вже забула.
Це така юнацько-дитяча
організація, яка саме консолідувала
українців, виховувала
молодь в дусі патріотизму.
А Просвіти пам'ятаєте?
От сама назва Просвіта.
Це освітні такі осередки.
І от тиск саме на такі
організації і заборона діяльності
деяких, і фізична розправа
з їхніми учасниками,
різні були аспекти полонізації,
але призводять до того,
що бути українцем, насправді,
іноді було навіть небезпечно.
І заявляти про те, що ти
цікавишся історією, спілкуватись
українською мовою в деяких
установах було доволі небезпечно.
Крім того - це вплив через освіту.
От якщо, наприклад, ви чуєте
навколо себе тільки іноземну мову?
Чи будете ви зберігати свою рідну?
Не знаю.
Давайте говорити інше,
якщо у нас державна мова українська,
чи всі українці
користуються нею в побуті?
Ні. А чому?
Тому що ми маємо вплив
іноземної мови на нас.
Так. Через те, що є вплив середовища.
Наприклад, в Києві дуже багато
людей говорить російською.
Відповідно, тоді багато людей
в містах говорили польською.
Освіта польською.
І все це мало б привчити
молодь, школярів, студентів,
послуговуватись польською
мовою і піднести її статус.
Тому ця програма – вона,
насправді, була доволі дієвою.
Але українці, оскільки все таки
вони чинили опір Австро-Угорській імперії
зберегли українську
мову і українську освіту.
Вони не дуже одразу готові
були піддаватися на всі ці впливи.
Подивіться, будь ласка, на світлини.
Перед вами школи Тернопільщини.
Це так звані утраквістичні
школи, двомовні.
І от офіційно, тут де у
нас зображені люди,
тут у нас є символи польської
державності, карта.
Вчителі, як представники держави,
вони мали теж виконувати певні правила.
Розповідати про Польську державу.
Частина вчителів були етнічні поляки, вони
взагалі не говорили українською мовою.
І реакція української
школярської спільноти про те,
що вчитися в школі польською
мовою дітям не подобалось.
Ось ця програма утраквістичних
шкіл була започаткована в 1924 році.
Формально частина предметів
мала викладатися польською,
частинка - українською.
Реально польська влада
направляла в українські школи
польських вчителів, які взагалі
не розуміли української мови.
До речі, така ситуація була не новою.
Наприклад, ще до Першої
Світової війни, точно так само
діяла Російська
Імперія на польських теренах.
І поляки знали як це працює через те,
що на підконтрольних Російські Імперії
територіях, росіяни забороняли
спілкуватися польською мовою
в польських школах.
І поляки бачили цей ефект і, на жаль,
не зробили демократичні висновки.
Вони скористались досвідом для того, щоб
полонізувати територію Східної Галичини.
Кількість шкіл, насправді, і якість
їхньої освіти суттєво змінилася.
Український історик
Олександр Дмитрович Бойко
наводить таку статистику,
що якщо в Східній Галичині на
навчальному, до запровадження
цих утраквістичних шкіл, було 2418
українських шкіл, то на момент коли
введено розпорядження про їх створення,
кількість українських шкіл
зменшилась майже на 600,
а через два роки українських
шкіл залишилось лише 845.
Тобто, фактично більше ніж
1500 шкіл було ліквідовано,
вони або стали польськими,
або стали двомовними.
Фактично - вони стали польськими.
Чи чинили українці опір?
Можливо ви пам'ятаєте
- хто цей видатний діяч?
Шептицький.
Правильно, чудово!
Це Андрій Шептицький.
Отже, які були способи
чинити опір отакій полонізації.
Перше - це діяльність єдиного
україномовного навчального закладу.
Це Греко-Католицької
Львівської богословської академії.
Чому? Оскільки священики греко-католики
працювали з місцевими жителями,
україномовними, то вчити їх
польської було абсолютно нелогічно.
І тому, плюс - дуже великий
авторитет самого
Митрополита Шептицького, який
був відомий далеко за межами України.
І дійсно був дуже впливовий,
тому його ось така активність
теж сприяла збереженню
цього навчального закладу.
І були два так званих катакомбних
навчальних заклади, які діяли нелегально.
Серед них, наприклад,
український університет.
Він насправді, от уявіть собі
ситуацію: так, ви отримували освіту,
студенти ходили нелегально,
викладачі працювали нелегально.
Студенти отримували диплом,
його не визнавали в Польщі
але визнавали, скажімо,
в сусідній Австрії.
І з одного боку університет ніби є,
але з іншого боку - начебто і немає.
Ця ситуація, насправді,
дратувала поляків,
через те що нелегальна освіта
дійсно мала підтримку.
Наприклад, в часи розквіту в університеті
навчалось 1500 студентів
і викладало 54 професори.
Уявіть собі, нелегально.
Насправді, це був один із способів, як
же все-таки надавати українську освіту,
україномовну освіту і підтримувати тих
студентів, які не хотіли полонізуватися.
Тому це один із способів.
І ще дуже велика роль все-таки
Греко-Католицької церкви,
священики якої, так як і раніше
в часи Австро-Угорської імперії,
підтримували розвиток освіти,
підтримували молодь,
дуже часто виступали такими
моральними авторитетами в певних питаннях.
Щодо економічної ситуації.
Можливо ви пам’ятаєте,
чим і зараз славиться,
які процеси відбуваються
на західно-українських землях
що там такого економічно-ресурсного,
привабливого не тільки
для української економіки є?
Це для нас велика проблема.
Ліси! Карпатські ліси!
Правильно. Карпатські ліси.
Так само думали і поляки.
Вони планомірно перетворювали,
насправді, зберігали статус
Східної Галичини - що це така колонія, з
якої ми будемо викачувати ресурси.
В той момент була ще нафта.
Звичайно, що ще деревина.
І вони продовжували діяти таким
чином, щоб в Східній Галичині
було дуже мало промислових
підприємств, які займалися переробкою.
Відповідно, більшість
населення займалось чим?
Сільським господарством.
А землі Західної України
не настільки родючі
щоб прямо з цього збагатіти, тому
були проблеми економічного плану.
Плюс поляки підвищували податки,
плюс економічні кризи,
світові, які на все це впливали.
Головні галузі так і зберігались - це
видобування корисних копалин,
а переробляли їх на території Польщі,
потім готову продукцію ввозили на
територію Східної Галичини.
А що коштує дорожче -
сировина або готова продукція?
Готова продукція. Так.
Тому уявіть собі, що
українці спиляли ліс,
деревину віддали в Польщу,
в Польщі з неї,
наприклад, зробили меблі,
українці на деревині заробили
не багато, але мають
купити дорожчі польські меблі.
Це дуже простий приклад і,
відповідно, українці втрачали в заробітку.
Через те, що заробляли
менше, відповідно, інвестувати
гроші українці у власний
розвиток не могли.
І інвестори, і, взагалі, іноземний
капітал або заможні поляки
які намагались тут
щось відкрити і працювати.
Проте були і такі щасливі випадки,
насправді, це планомірна
робота, дуже активна.
Ви бачите зараз емблему
українського кооперативу «Маслосоюз».
Чи пам’ятаєте ви, що таке кооперативи?
І взагалі, що таке кооперація?
Ну, англійською мовою
«cooperation»? Що це означає?
Коли декілька людей об’єднуються. Так.
Насправді, цей «Маслосоюз» -
це явище доволі унікальне. Чому?
Тому що вони виготовляли продукцію,
яку купували не лише в Східній
Галичині і не лише в Польщі.
Вони вивозили, довозили масло
якимось чином навіть в Палестину.
В чому їх суть? Треба
було навчати людей
як правильно збирати молоко,
бути конкурентоспроможними.
Насправді, дуже багато публікацій.
Наприклад, щоб зробити рекламу,
щоб заохотити купувати продукцію
«Маслосоюзу», ці підприємці
відкривали в містах маленькі кафе
(отак як зараз в Україні іноді буває)
і пропонували людям
не просто купувати масло
або інші молокопродукти, а випити кави,
спробувати якісь різні сорти
сиру, відчути гарну атмосферу.
Таким чином вони привчали, що їхні товари
завжди якісні, смачні і є широкий вибір.
В умовах польського тиску, це було
доволі важко, але ось «Маслосоюз» -
вони першими холодильні установки
почали завозити, купували автомобілі
для того щоб збирати
молоко у віддалених селах
і, таким чином, вони
привчали українців виробляти
потрібну продукцію,
самоорганізовуватись, вчитися.
Ось такі кооперативні об’єднання – вони,
насправді, були єдиною альтернативою
такій репресивній і
депресивній політиці економічній
яку впровадила Польська республіка.
Ситуація ускладнювалась
такими програмами як осадництво.
Слово насправді для нас співзвучне.
Хто такі осадники?
В 1920 році польський
Сейм дозволив надавати
в Україні землі колишнім військовим,
або просто полякам, які хотіли переїхати,
або просто погоджувались
переїхати на землі Східної Галичини.
Вони отримували ділянки і отримували
пільгові умови використання землі.
Навіщо це було?
Вони розріджували українців
і вони дуже часто виконували
такі функції - вони
спостерігали за ситуацією,
знали що відбувається, можливо розуміли
коли там є вибухонебезпечна
ситуація в плані повстань.
Я не можу вам сказати, що ці люди
були, наприклад, дуже заможними.
Є така документальна
світлина - це родина осадників,
яка проживала на
сучасній Івано-Франківщині.
У них абсолютно простий будиночок,
немає ніяких палаців і хоромів.
Але вони представляли інтереси
Польської держави, вони отримували пільги.
В той час, як українські
селяни отримували вищі податки
і не мали можливості, наприклад,
за державної підтримки
купити собі щось додаткове
або взяти в оренду
додатковий наділ землі.
Це не призвело до полонізації,
це призвело до зростання
нетерпимості національної.
Українці негативно ставляться до поляків
і, відповідно, різні бували ситуації.
Поляки намагалися об’єднатися і
протидіяти опору місцевого населення.
Замість полонізації уряд
отримав ситуацію нетерпимості.
Вирішено було цю ситуацію
теж силовим методом.
Пацифікація, примирення, але
це примирення не було мирним.
Да, така гра слів в нас виходить. Чому?
Це були силові методи,
які мали налякати українців.
Я б навіть сказала - залякати.
Подивіться, будь ласка, на світлину
- це зруйнована читальня Просвіти.
От просто військові, поліція прийшли і
дізнались, що це український осередок.
Ви можете побачити портрет
Тараса Григоровича Шевченка.
Для Західної України, так само, як і для
Наддніпрянських земель, для УРСР –
це, все таки, для людей
Шевченко був певним лідером,
певним еталоном і натхненням.
Люди вірили, що його
тексти - культура українська,
все таки об’єднають українські
землі в єдину державу.
І тут, плюс, Просвіта аполітична,
вони не закликали – там, бери
зброю, борись за незалежність.
Це, в основному, культурні заходи,
це публічні читання, театралізації.
Нічого такого забороненого.
Але поляки чудово розуміли - що
починається з молоді, з дітей, з Просвіти,
а далі почнуться політичні організації,
які вже інакше захищатимуть
інтереси українства.
Тому наступ був доволі жорстким, було
і побиття, і ув’язнення, навіть вбивства.
Через деякий час, через
те, що, коли стабілізувалась
економіка після світової
економічної кризи.
Коли відбулись певні
події в середині Польщі.
Ще хочу згадати такий
важливий факт. Як ви думаєте?
Яким чином українство могло
вплинути на пацифікацію?
Як можна було змусити польській
уряд трошки полегшати
свої дії, все таки більш демократично
ставитись до українців?
Тільки протестами, я вважаю.
Так, але якщо вони протестували
в Україні, в Східній Галичині,
то поляки їх би розганяли,
били, придушували ці виступи.
Що можна робити ще?
Де ще в нас українці
так організовувались,
що вони могли сказати
своє слово, вимагати?
Ті українці, які проживали в
Польщі, вони теж виходили на вулицю.
Так, але де в нас велика така діаспора?
Ще, крім Польщі, за океаном?
Канада. Так.
Оскільки багато українців проживало
в діаспорі, плюс українці проживали
на території Німеччини,
на території Австрії,
на території інших європейських держав.
Коли починають відбуватись ці
акції, чим їх пояснювали поляки?
Діяльністю націоналістів.
Коли Ліга Націй почала, коли стало
відомо, що відбувається в Україні,
коли українці зверталися до
журналістів, описували всі ці страхіття.
В Європі почалась хвиля незадоволення
і українці нагадували, що
Антанта обіцяла нам,
що поляки будуть
дотримуватись наших прав,
будуть зберігати українську
ідентичність в законних рамках.
А тут вам пацифікація.
Представники Польщі говорили, що це лише
реакція на терористичні акти, на вбивства.
І тоді діаспора почала підіймати
це питання і врешті-решт
частина європейців почала тиснути,
дипломати, що якось ви
унормуйте свої стосунки.
І після пацифікації був
такий короткий період
до початку цього загострення
міжнародного, до Другої Світової війни,
коли, все таки, частина
українців намагалась
піти на компроміс і деякі, скажімо,
питання трошки знайшли полегшення.
Але, насправді, якщо
говорити про українські землі
у складі інших держав,
ті, які не були підконтрольні
Радянському Союзу,
а це у нас Румунія і Чехословаччина,
то поляки діяли доволі жорстко.
І ось такі дії як, я
повторюю: осадництво,
як запровадження утраквістичних шкіл і,
звичайно, як пацифікація
- вони демонстрували, що
все таки польський режим
намагається силою
придушити українське питання.
Чому?
Це, по-перше, і бажання створити буфер,
буферну зону, щоб не було загрози
з боку Радянського Союзу.
А як ви думаєте, які події
30 років трошки розчарували
українців з боку діяльності
Радянського Союзу,
який українізацію запроваджував до цього,
говорив про те, як українському народу в
Радянському Союзі живеться нормально.
Голодомор!
Правильно, чудово.
Насправді, коли в Східній Галичині
дізнались про Голодомор,
то було певне розчарування
і розуміння того,
що Польська держава
чинить доволі брутально.
Але, вона не була такою
тоталітарною і тут існували вибори,
і були легальні українські партії - це
вже буде тема нашого наступного уроку.
Але ось в плані економічного життя
і в плані державного тиску, Польща
абсолютно не обирала засобів.
Я розумію, що наш час підходить до кінця.
Я дякую вам. Сподіваюсь,
що до наступного уроку
ви зробите таке доволі
просте домашнє завдання.
Ви визначите основні наслідки
- до чого призвело осадництво,
до чого призвела пацифікація,
до чого призвела освітня політика
і ця економічна політика, коли
українські землі не мали підтримки
і розвивались як колоніальна
частинка Польської Республіки.
Тому дякую вам за увагу і
до наших нових зустрічей.
Перевірка знань.
Польська влада своїх людей
переселяла на території України
і вони … (як я думаю, як
я пам’ятаю з цього уроку)
вони жили на території України
і слідкували за рухами людей.
Тобто, вони якось слідкували-чи є якісь
бунти серед українського народу і якось
розбавляли український народ поляками.
Історію України я люблю, знаю.
Це – пацифікація. Всього цього не було.
Розповідали і трохи
пам’ятаємо і пам’ятали,
Український Митрополит
греко-католицької церкви
і засновник єдиного
українського закладу в ті часи,
який був дозволений
польським урядом. Ось так.
Коли з декількома язиками, але там як, що
повертаємось до предмета який нам дали,
до історії і до цього часу,
то це - польсько-українські
школи де, як показували результати
(як правильно сказати)
як показувала історія - це більш
з поглибленням польської мови
Тобто діти, які були в школах більш
здобували інформацію на польській мові.